few months ago I went to Miami invited
by Jordan Peterson and daily wire to do
a panel discussion on the book of Exodus
it was a really amazing experience we uh
we got through half the book in a week
you know a lot of pretty intense
discussions
all very um
very positive and kind of building
towards a common understanding the
series comes out now it's out on daily
wire Plus for those who are interested
and we will be doing the second part in
January we'll be going I'll be going
back to Miami and we're going to film
the second part of The Exodus series
starting at the law and then moving
towards the end so I thought that to
kind of celebrate this and to uh
to add more to the discussion I would do
my own Exodus Series so I will be going
through the first part of the book of
Exodus in the next few weeks
um doing my interpretation these are
just part of the interpretations that I
brought to the Forum in Miami if you're
interested in more of course go there
and you'll see the not only my
interpretation but everybody coming
together in discussion you can see
people react to what I'm saying and and
also Jordan and I exchange on our vision
of what Exodus is about and so we're
going to start now with the first
chapter first and second chapter looking
at Israel as slaves in Egypt
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
of course in order to have a symbolic
vision of what is happening in scripture
you always have to
be comparing the images to other books
especially in Exodus to what happened in
Genesis so we'll see that there are many
many references in in Exodus going back
to Genesis and also as Christians we
also want to be looking towards the
future and looking towards the manner in
which Exodus is prefiguring uh Christ
and how the story of Christ kind of
fills in some of the brings together
some of the elements of Exodus now of
course in this whole series I will be
looking at the text itself giving my own
interpretation based on what I see there
but of course this interpretation is
always deeply steeped in especially the
works of Saint Gregor of Nissa uh the
life of Moses the I some of my
interpretations will let's say push
things further than his but they're
rooted in the structure that he sees in
the text and the manner and the types of
identifications he makes the analogies
he makes uh and so most of the time when
I push it further I'm using his
analogies and going deeper in into the
analogy that he does in his book because
his book is a nice slim very efficient
book uh and here we're going to add a
little more detail to that I'm also
basing my work on the work of Saint from
the Syrian who I mentioned many times
who who wrote a wonderful book on the
hymns on on Paradise a poem about the
mountain and so of course it's not about
Exodus but his mountain of paradise is
also the mountain of of Zion it's also
the the Mount Sinai it's all the
mountains in scripture end up being
contained in Saint ephron's vision of
the Mountain of paradise and because of
that his work really comes very neatly
against the work of Saint Gregory of
Nissa
um his life of Moses
and so we will start the the text I'll
be reading through the text
um some parts I will go through quickly
and other parts we will kind of stop at
more and so we start at the beginning
these are the names of the sons of
Israel who went to Egypt with Jacob each
with his family Reuben Simeon Levi and
Judah issachar zebulum and Benjamin Dan
and naftali Gad and Asher the
descendants of Jacob numbered 70 in all
Joseph was already in Egypt
now I think it's important to understand
right at the outset that there seems to
be an attempt to create something like a
microcosm of the world in the
descendants of Jacob the 70 nations are
important they're named in when uh
After the flood God names the
descendants of Noah and he separates
them into these 70 Nations and this
notion of the 70 Nations is an important
tradition
um because the law was kind of given to
these 70 Nations and so here we see this
17 notion of 70 as Joseph uh Jacob's
sons being a kind of microcosm within
Egypt
um it's important to remember you know
how they came to Egypt through Joseph
because we're going to see how it's
going to have some impact in the manner
in what happens to them while they're in
Egypt
and so now Joseph and all his brothers
and all the generation died but the
Israelites were exceedingly fruitful
they multiplied greatly increased in
numbers and became so numerous that the
land was filled with them then a new
king to whom Joseph meant nothing came
to power in Egypt look he said to his
people the Israelites have become far
too numerous for us come we must deal
surely with them they will become even
more numerous and if War breaks out
we'll join our enemies fight against us
and leave the country
so what's important to understand is the
relationship to the stranger this is
really one of the keys to looking at the
story in Exodus
the the character of Egypt or Egypt as
as a figure appears in Genesis it
appears in in the moments where in
Abraham uh goes to Egypt and his wife is
taken from him for a certain amount of
time and then uh Abraham has to tell the
the Pharaoh that it's his wife in order
to kind of get her back and this causes
plagues in Egypt because the Pharaoh
tries to take Abraham's wife now you can
see that this story the story we're
going to see in Exodus is a kind of an
expansion on that theme which is that
the stranger and we have to understand
it not of course just in a strict ethnic
way or a strict a strict way but
understanding the notion of The Stranger
In general as a category of experience
of that which is not you right that
which is is does not fit within your
identity no matter how you or that which
you don't recognize that is not your
friend that is not you that is not your
friend that is something that is outside
of you how that stranger the
relationship with that stranger has to
be the proper one because there's others
a danger which is that if you're not
careful in relationship with that which
is uh the stranger the stranger will
take your potential from you right and
this is of course this is what war is
you know someone attacks another country
and they take their potential and they
you could say all those they they can
also reduce you to potential and this is
what we're going to see happen in in the
story now of course this is the
important of understanding the woman in
this in this context the wife as the one
who provides the children the one who
the womb out of which the children of
Abraham and also the children's the
children of Israel will will come and so
though there's a relationship between
the land because the land is that out of
which the fruits come there's a
relationship between that and the woman
as the one out of which the children
come to the increase of your identity to
the increase of the identity of the of
the of the patriarch and so this is the
important to understand that it's what
we're going to see now is that
you can have a proper relationship with
the stranger but if the Pharaoh forgets
you okay because the Pharaoh has
forgotten what Joseph has done for him
now the Israelites appear as a danger to
him because there's no connection
between the two it's like now they
appear only as as strangers and
strangers which have to be reduced to
potential in order to serve the function
of the the Pharaoh now
there's a little trick in the text which
is which is important to understand the
Bible is very complicated and it's very
subtle in what it proposes now of course
the fact that the Pharaoh subjugates the
Israelites in uh in the story is seen as
something which is bad and seen as
something which is
which is bad for Israel
but we have to understand that
Israel or Joseph played a role in
bringing about the situation something
like a swing from extreme to extremes
we have to remember that in the Book of
Genesis
Joseph saved the Egyptians from famine
but the way in which he saved the
Egyptians from famine
meant that the Egyptians had to give up
all their land to pharaoh and they had
to give up one-fifth of all their
production to pharaoh and so what Joseph
did in Saving Egypt is that he
centralized the power of the state and
so in some ways he Joseph was part of
what created the the Tyrant which would
then when he forgot Joseph would then
now turn around and act on on the
Israelites and that's really important
to understand it's important to
understand in terms of power in general
that you can you can think about it it's
a simple analogy in terms of what's
going on now and our culture is that
when we move towards centralization of
power because we because we have power
at the time and so we want to get power
for ourselves into the system so that so
that it serves our interests we have to
know that if once power is centralized
that if it forgets you then you will
fall under the thumb of that power you
know and so that power will have a kind
of will of its own will have a reality
of its own and so this is what we see in
the story of of Joseph is that Joseph uh
and it's not a it's not a bad or a good
situation it just describes the reality
and it's in some ways Joseph did it in
order to save to save Egypt and to also
save his Israel during the famine but
the side effect of that which is
something like Joseph's sin or Joseph's
the the dark aspect of Joseph all the
characters in the Old Testament have a
have a dark aspect to them if you look
at the story carefully the dark aspect
of Joseph
is that he centralizes the power of the
Pharaoh and then that becomes the tool
by which his own people will then be
subjugated later and so that's important
to understand as we as we move but what
we're going to see is we're going to
understand that what the Pharaoh is
going to be doing is trying to reduce
Israel
to only potential right and you can if
you understand that then you'll notice
why some of the analogies that are are
used are there and so
so it says so they will so they put the
Israel the Egyptians put slave masters
over them to oppress them with forced
labor and they built pitham and Ramses
as store cities for Pharaoh but the more
they were oppressed the more they
multiplied and spread so the Egyptians
came to dread the Israelites and work
them ruthlessly they made their lives
bitter with harsh labor in brick and
mortar and with all kinds of work in the
fields in all their harsh labor the
Egyptians worked them ruthlessly
the king of the Egyptians said to the
Hebrew midwives whose names were sifra
and Pua when you are helping the Hebrew
women during childbirth on the delivery
stool if you see that the baby is a boy
kill him but if it is a girl let her
live The Midwives however feared God and
did not do what the king of Egypt had
told them to do they let the boys live
then the kings of Egypt summoned The
Midwives and asked them why have you
done this why have you let the boys live
The Midwives answered Pharaoh Hebrew
women are not like Egyptian women
they're vigorous and give birth before
the Midwife midwives arrive so God was
kind to The Midwives and the people
increased and became even more numerous
and because the midwives feared God he
gave them families of Their Own
and so let's continue just a little bit
then Pharaoh gave his order to all his
people every boy every Hebrew boy that
is born you must throw into the Nile but
let every girl live
and so
if you look at if you look at this you
will notice that the analogies that are
brought together are really about
something like reducing Israel to a
feminine to a feminine role in Egypt as
as just this potential and you can see
it in terms of the way in which uh
Israel is analogy that are described it
talks about making them work in the
field right it talks about the idea of
talked about the idea of making their
life bitter and relating them to the
building part of the the the the country
so it's like bricks and mortar this is
also relating Egypt to Babel when it has
this idea of of bricks and mortar
because that is the difference you know
that is how Babel was was built and so
it's really trying to conjoin the idea
of the Pharaoh with the Tyrant with the
Tyrant of Babel and the the reduction of
Israel to their feminine role and this
becomes very explicit in telling the
midwives to kill the baby boys and let
the girls live now
many people find that odd that you know
it's like why would the Hebrew midwives
ever do that why would the Hebrew
midwives ever uh kill their own boys and
let the Hebrew girls live and you have
to notice what it is that's going on so
there's a lot of things Crossing
themselves this idea of let's say
feminizing the the uh the Israelites in
relationship to Egypt and one is that
there's a relationship between
uh let's say
you could say that the Pharaoh is
wanting to empower
the Israelite women
to kill their men to kill their males
than themselves so it's like the
centralized power and the Tyranny the
tyrannical power is wanting to give
power to the women in order to to kill
the masculinity right to castrate the
their own their own uh Nation
in order to reduce Israel to things that
Egypt only acts on right that they have
no that they don't have uh their own
um let's say Will and their own identity
but rather they only become
food and potential for the Egyptian
Nation
um
and so because the The Midwives refused
to do that you know then the the
Israelites grow in number and they are
in some ways they refuse to participate
with the tyrant in order to do that and
so they
they they get families of their own and
they they participate in the they
Ally themselves with Israel they Ally
themselves with their people because
you know it's it's important to
understand that how these
identities work right and so
think about now and so and there's
nothing wrong sometimes with like a kind
of assimilation now in this case we
don't want the assimilation to happen
but you can understand that for example
in Canada we have people that are in the
United States you have people that come
from Germany they come from England and
come from Ireland they come from Italy
and there's a manner in which they
accept to become only vehicles for the
identity of America to a certain extent
uh and and that is that can be okay at a
certain level you know but of course
here you have a very extreme version of
that in the story of uh of Egypt and
Israel where you know you see it as like
not only being reduced to just labor
basically and and just potential for the
Egyptian identity but that is in some
ways the way in which uh tyrannies work
and tyrannies manifest themselves
so of course now the the image becomes
very explicit when it comes to the the
final image which is that the Pharaoh
tells his people that to take all the
Hebrew boys and throw them into the
water and so now you really have this
final image right of
of wanting to reduce the Israelite
identity to water into and throw it into
this into the fluidity
of the of potential right and so all the
images kind of come together if you see
them
um and what you have now is of course a
flood
and this is you know we know the denial
floods and that's part of the the story
of of how the Nile functions
but here we have to understand it also
as the flood in Genesis there's the
throwing the baby uh Israelites into the
water becomes now an image of the end of
a world or the end of a generation of
course it's not the end of all the all
the Israelites but it's like it's kind
of like the reduction of a generation
and you know the the miracle is very
similar to the story of Noah which is
that
although it's not explicitly said this
way you can imagine like the entire
generation gets of of Israelite boys
gets eliminated and thrown into the Nile
and all of that gets reduced to one
character that is saved from the
catastrophe and that is of course Moses
um and so we have to be able to see
these themes so you can understand it
and as the as kind of the end of of the
civilizational part in Genesis where the
sons of Cain become very very powerful
and create these these civilizations be
create these cities these great cities
and these cities are are violent and and
dangerous towards the people and then
that leads to a catastrophe which is the
reduction of the generation uh back into
potential and the survival of one person
now this is a mini version of that but
it follows the same story Trope as what
we see in uh in Genesis just before the
flood good
right now a man from the tribe of Levi
married a levied woman and she became
pregnant and gave birth to a son when
she saw that she that he was a fine
child she hit him for three months but
when she could hide him no longer she
got a Papyrus basket for him and coded
it with tar and pitch and she placed the
child in it and put it among the Reeds
along the bank of the Nile his sister
stood at a distance to see what would
happen to him when Pharaoh's daughter
went down to the Nile to bathe and her
attendants were walking along the
riverbank she saw the basket among the
Reeds and sent her female slave to get
it she opened it and saw the baby he was
crying and she felt sorry for him this
is one of the Hebrew babies who said
then his then his sister asked Pharaoh's
daughter shall I go and get one of the
Hebrew women to nurse the baby for you
yes go she answered so the girl went and
got his baby's mother Pharaoh's daughter
said to her take this baby and nurse him
for me and I will pay you so the woman
took the baby and nursed him when the
child Grew Older she took him to
Pharaoh's daughter and he became her son
she named him Moses saying I drew him
from the water
so I hope you noticed that
when this happens so you could say that
everything is reduced to the feminine
and so when I said that it sounded like
I was saying it was just negative but
here we now see the positive aspect of
of that happening almost like the side
effect of that happening everything is
reduced to the Nile to the water to the
feminine in a desire to CH to transform
Israel into a let's say just into
potential for the for the um
for the Egyptian state but now we see
all these women notice how every
character now in this part of the story
is a Woman except for Moses so now we
are in the watery world we really are in
the in the the feminine world and what
we have is an image of Noah in the ark
on the waters and so the ark is of
course a feminine image of a womb a box
uh you know a container which holds the
world and protects the world and kind of
carries the seed of the world into the
next the next World so this is where we
are now and we can understand that of
course just in terms of a woman giving
birth you know uh the the woman carries
the seed of the man in her body and then
she you know she gives it body and
transitions the the the the the the seed
into the new world as the child is born
so this is what we're seeing happen
that is why the characters are all
feminine if you notice even even it says
it's it's explicitly says that the the
pharaoh's daughter sends her female
servant to get uh Moses out of the water
so you have this image of Moses
in the in the ark all the dead Hebrew
babies at the bottom of the water right
we really have this this scene which is
uh which is reminiscent of the flood and
now you have the Guardians of Moses
during that time being his mother his
sister and the pharaoh's daughter
and what we we're going to see is of
course Saint Gregory of Nissa here
really uh gives us a good understanding
of the difference between what we could
call the
the foreign wife or the foreign woman
and then the the the woman of your own
group and the woman of your own identity
and he's he talks about the the foreign
woman as being the
all the tools which are given us by the
secular world that is all those things
that are not
directly sacred from the church all the
knowledge all the all the um the wisdom
you know the the sciences that come from
the secular world and saying Greg and
it's a good way to understand that it's
a good way to understand it's outer
knowledge it's outer you know outer
wisdom but as a Gregory says it's
dangerous to us and you can see the man
in which Egypt acts upon uh upon Moses
it's dangerous to him but it can also be
a help in the right proportion or in the
right uh relationship and so this is an
example of where the the collaboration
between uh Moses's sister and the the
pharaoh's daughter which is the inner
part and the outer part the notion of
the uh Saint Gregor Nisa talks about
really like the church and then all the
Pagan philosophy and and secular
knowledge collaborating together in
order to preserve serve Moses and in
Gregor of Nissa Moses is really
something like the individual or
something like the person that is any
person now it's not a man or a woman
every person has these aspects in in
them and it's something like the free
the free person that is capable of
exercising their will within you know in
service to God and that and is acted
upon by these different forces the
Pharaoh being this this kind of foreign
Tyrant and then of course these women
playing uh playing the role of something
like of true knowledge through true
wisdom and then also secular knowledge
and secular wisdom collaborating towards
the survival of of uh of Moses
and so the the idea and it's important
to understand and those of you who have
listened to Matsu's recent discussion I
mean he really he really
Sean shown a light on it if you saw what
he talked about with Jordan Peterson in
terms of uh the idea of that something
he said something like the entire Bible
is about finding
someone who's not you you know that is
not hostile to you like entering into a
relationship at the right distance with
the other that is that is it says
something like a wife which is not too
close to you but then is also let's say
not um not so far from you in terms of
the stranger that that she will take
everything that she will take everything
from you towards the stranger so finding
that relationship and you see that if
you read Exodus that way it makes it
makes so much sense and it can also help
you understand some weird aspects of
Exodus which we'll see a little later
but I can mention right now which is
that you know when you read the
genealogy of of uh Moses it turns out
Moses is a is actually a child of incest
that his his uh
his father married uh a woman who was
his cousin or maybe his father's sister
it's not totally clear because I think
there are different strains of the text
but no matter which strain of the text
you find in the masoretic text for
example uh she's clearly his father's
sister which would have been a Totoro
taboo and so there's a man in which this
this problem too close and too far which
you see in the story of Abraham already
in the relationship to the Pharaoh which
is that Abraham says to the Pharaoh that
that Sarah is his sister which is
weirdly kind of half true and then it's
also his wife and so there's this
problem of too close and you can see
like the entire story is about finding
this relationship who is the stranger
who I can Unite with and who will and
who we can kind of collaborate in love
towards something more rather than
rather than being a relationship that
kind of that kind of take reduces me to
potential for their identity um
so one day after Moses had grown up he
went out where his own people were and
watched them in their hard labor he saw
an Egyptian beating a Hebrew one of his
own people
looking this way and that seeing no one
he killed the Egyptian and hid him in
the sand
the next day he went out and saw two
Hebrews fighting he asked the one in the
wrong why are you hitting your fellow
Hebrew the man said who made you ruler
and judge over us
are you are you thinking of killing me
as you kill the Egyptian then Moses was
afraid and thought
what I did must have become known
when Pharaoh heard of this he tried to
kill Moses but Moses fled from pharaoh
and went to live in Midian where he sat
down by a well to do that a little later
and so here we have Moses within the
bosom of the Egyptians within the wisdom
of the stranger remembering his identity
remembering who he is you know what is
his origin
and in doing that he decides to rid
himself of the Egyptian now Saint Gregor
of Nissa has a very powerful vision of
this he sees
the Egyptian as the as the Garment of
skin and so in his text he talks about
how he killed the uncircumcised Egyptian
you know this this Egyptian which
represents the outer part of our
existence and so you can understand the
outer part of our existence as this
these let's say the uh secular knowledge
the way that I mentioned before as also
you know let's say in some ways even our
biological reality as this outer shell
for our our experience but then also you
know all our all the all our passions
all the things which draw us away from
ourselves you know all our um
all our desires they draw draw us away
from ourselves which can become which
can enslave us and so this is all these
images get kind of mixed in together and
saying Gregory of needs his text but
it's a it's I think the the if you
understand the Deep uh scriptural
narrative you'll notice that these
things are are there in the text and
this is this is what if you understand
that the stranger just draws you out of
yourself into outer into the outer
things and in in the um in the text
especially in in Exodus you'll see like
the Egyptians have chariots you'll see
that later there's this image of them
also representing this kind of even
technology Civilization this outer
aspect of reality which can be useful if
the that you're in the right
relationship but can also draw you away
from yourself and enslave you right and
so that's the basic structure that you
see and so
Moses killing the Egyptian is the
beginning of what saint Gregor Nissa
will call the removal of the garments of
skin that is a kind of ascetic movement
in which we remove these outer aspects
we kind of kind of move into the heart
we could say uh in order to gain what is
essential return to the the uh the
identity right the Israel return to the
name that we have received from above
and shed the the excessive accumulated
things that come from the outside or
accumulate themselves from the outside
and so we see that this is what Moses
does now but there's something there's a
manner in which he is not ready for the
consequence of that like he's not in the
position the proper position to do that
he does although you know even Saint
Gregory I think he he sees this as a
good thing killing the Egyptians part of
the story but in the text when you
notice you see what he does he says kind
of looks left and right he kills the
Egyptian he hides him and then he
realized that he's been discovered and
you see that in some ways he's not in
the proper position you could say that
he isn't in the position to become the
leader of his people and so because of
that when he kills the Egyptian he does
it it doesn't connect him to his people
his people don't trust him he hasn't
gone up the mountain you could say he
hasn't reached into that place out of
which he can receive Authority from
above and so killing the Egyptian leads
him into conflict even with his own
people his they're saying they they
start saying are you going to kill us
like you killed the Egyptian because
they can't discern him as being the
leader and in some ways he also isn't
ready for what he needs to do and he has
to go through an entire process in which
to you know in order to reach that
Readiness
um
and so then of course Moses leaves Egypt
and goes out into the world of the
midianites and this is really important
because if we understand the whole story
as this negotiation between you know
what is who is the right wife you could
say right what is the right potential we
need to associate ourselves with what is
the right extension of ourselves into
the world outside which won't enslave us
and won't take over us you know how much
how many hours a day should you work at
your job like how you know how much time
should you spend thinking about uh
investing your money or how much time
should you think about uh you know
fixing your house or whatever it is that
is these external things that serve you
and serve you in the sense that they can
become extensions of you and give you
potential in which to act in the world
but that always run the risk of
enslaving you and so here we'll notice
that Moses will now go out into the
midianites and the midianites are not
Israelites they are they are they are
strangers they are a different group but
he will find in them the right distance
you could say the right distance uh in
which he can unite himself with Midian
uh without losing himself without
becoming a slave to Midian and rather
their collaboration will lead to to more
to to a better a better sense of Israel
and also you know a good relationship
with Midian all right so Moses fled from
pharaoh and went to live in Midian where
he sat down by a well now a priest
immediate had seven daughters and they
came to draw water and fill the troughs
to water their father's flock some
Shepherds came along and drove them away
but Moses got up and came to their
rescue and watered their flock
when the girls returned to rarewell
their father he asked them why have you
returned so early today they answered an
Egyptian who rescued us from the
Shepherds he even Drew water for us and
and water the flock and where is he real
as his daughters why did you leave him
invite him to have something to eat
Moses agreed to stay with the man who
gave his daughter zipporah to Moses in
marriage zipporah gave birth to son and
Moses named him
gershom saying I have come I have become
a foreigner in a foreign land
during that long period the king of
Egypt died the Israel the Israelites
groaned in their slavery and cried out
and their cry for help
because of their slavery went up to God
God heard their groaning and he
remembered his Covenant with Abraham
with Isaac and Jacob
so God looked on the Israelites and was
concerned about them
what's going on here
now of course this story is a little
representation it reprises the image of
finding a wife and finding a wife in the
same situation that Moses is if you look
at the Patriarchs they um Isaac and
Jacob they find their wives in a kind of
like a little further out from
themselves in the you know the house of
of leban in Lebanon you could say they
find their their wives there and they
have a similar situation where they come
to a well and the well of course is this
is in some ways the feminine itself it's
this water from below and it's this
potential from below and so this is the
place where you you find your wife now
in this case what's interesting is that
Moses comes to the well and he
he basically chases away the these
people that are hostile towards the the
daughter of uh of the priest the Midian
of very well
and then he Waters the flocks of of uh
of zipporah of real well he he Waters
their flocks and this is of course the
he draws water out of the well there are
different versions of it like sometimes
it's the woman who draws the water and
then Waters the flocks of the man and
now here in this case it's Moses who
draws the water and and Waters the
flocks of uh of the of zipporah but it
what it represents it really is this
capacity to join with the waters it
really is in some ways an image of the
marriage itself and you know this is
where Moses finds the right Foreigner
you could say in for which to be able to
join himself with
um and so this leads him it's kind of
like a little version of going out into
the wilderness
if you look at how the um the Egypt the
Israelites will leave Egypt and go out
into the Wilderness moving towards the
promised land now Moses has a similar
situation he leaves Egypt finds himself
in this Wilderness where he has to fight
he has to fight off the The Strangers
which is what Israel will go through
when they leave the when they leave
Egypt as well they'll have to fight in
order to move towards the mountain the
Mountain of God and so Moses has a
similar situation he leaves the he
leaves Egypt and now he has to fight and
he finds the right potential he finds
water and water also means finding a
wife which is what will happen to Israel
when they also leave Egypt they will
fight and try to find water until they
reach the Mountain of God and so we will
see that Moses will encounter God in the
burning bush in the next sections and
this will be a microcosm remember that
these stories they really have this
fractal structure and if you if you
start to see it that way you'll notice
these little versions happening and then
bigger versions happening as you as you
move forward and so the little story of
Moses
leaving leaving uh killing the Egyptian
right this is what's going to happen of
course in the plagues killing the
Egyptian firstborn leaving uh Egypt uh
fighting off the strangers finding water
and then moving up the mountain this is
what Moses is happens at a little scale
so he's becoming what he needs to become
he's becoming Israel he's becoming the
head of Israel uh by manifesting the
pattern you know in a seed form and then
he will reproduce the pattern in in uh
in rescuing and bringing Israel out of
uh out of Egypt
and so I I thought this could be a
little uh beginning so we're going to to
stop here for today and uh there is a
lot more that I could obviously say
about these these texts
um it's important to notice this idea of
the reduction of the multiple into one
when Moses uh let's say becomes a little
Noah and floats on the ark over the
waters this is something which will
happen several times in scripture and
it's something that we have to
understand it's part of the stories that
feed into the story of Christ of course
because this is something that will
happen to Christ as well so once we see
this image in the the massacre of the
children in Egypt you can understand how
Herod wanting to kill all the children
uh the born the the the boys that are
born
in in Israel or in the area where Christ
is born is very similar to that there's
a there's this strange idea that
in some ways it's it's in order in in
the desire to eliminate the people
what happens is there's a reduction into
one and that reduction into one becomes
something like the seed for the next
world because it's like all the
potential is gathered into this one
place and then that becomes the seed for
for a new world and so this is not and
you know when I mentioned this in The
Exodus seminar uh a lot of people got
really offended and I understand because
it it's not a moral question I'm not
presenting you a moral dilemma I'm
presenting really an image of reality
and you can understand that
you know this is this is something that
you do all the time in your own
experience which is that when you if you
want to know
if you want to gather your energy you
have to eliminate every as if you want
to gather energy in a way that you can
act very efficiently or very strongly
you have to kind of eliminate all the
little ones all the little all the
little uh thoughts all the little
possibilities and you have to kind of
reduce things towards one and that is
something that you can do yourself but
sometimes it's also something that
happens to you in the sense that
sometimes all your possibilities get
taken away from you and the only thing
left is one
point of light or one little door that
appears in front of you
and if you if you understand that and
you take that door and you take that one
possibility then that will become the
seed for your new beginning uh you know
I've had that experience when I started
icon carving that's exactly what
happened to me you know I came back from
Africa after seven years of being a
volunteer and I tried to find a job I
tried to find all these different things
and nothing was working everything was
falling apart
you know I was running out of money I
was running out of possibilities you
know everything was getting reduced and
at some point as implausible as that
might might have seemed the only thing I
could do was carve icons it was the only
path in front of me and in some ways
this is what had been had happened all
my possibilities got shriveled up and
they got reduced into this one seed that
now was going to be fruitful and so I
think it's if we understand the
structure uh we can we can see why this
image gets reproduced in the story of
Noah in the story of Moses but not just
in the story of Moses it's going to
happen again in Exodus because when they
get to the promised land
there's only two people left from the
original people when they get there and
so there's this like reduction that
happens and we see the same uh of course
like I said in the in the the story of
Christ as the kind of ultimate version
of that and in the story of Christ it's
interesting because
there's this like weird reversals that
happen in that in the story of Jesus
because think about what happens in this
story now there's this reduction to the
one where the Egyptians kill the
children and now
that that causes Moses to appear right
and not only Moses to appear but like
Moses to be saved by the Pharaoh and
protected by the pharaoh's daughter
because you know it's like he's the only
one left or something like that she gets
he gets protected by the pharaoh's
daughter uh and also by his mother and
his sister and then he becomes the he
will become the leader of the Israelites
and the the seed of a new beginning now
Christ goes in reverse right the King of
Judea wants to kill him and so because
of that he massacres all these children
and that let's say makes Christ appear
as this bright bright light that flees
now from the promised land to Egypt in
order to protect themselves from the
King of Judea and so it's a weird
interesting reversal where Christ goes
to Egypt in order to be protected from
the the massacre and it kind of
condenses the story of the Exile from
from uh
from the I mean from the the leaving
Egypt in going to the promised land and
Joseph leaving his land going into Egypt
to be protected and so it's like those
two those two extremes which is one
Joseph going to Egypt and then the
Israelites leaving Egypt to go out back
to the promised land being condensed
into one story now the story of Jesus
does that all the time but you if you
know well the Old Testament you're going
to start to see it happen more and more
and just how crazy uh the that story is
how it just just smashes everything
together in ways that are sometimes just
hard to totally unpack uh and so I hope
that was a nice meditation on the first
few chapters of Exodus we will continue
for the next chapters the um start we're
starting with the burning bush and we're
going to look at the the structure of
the mountain the beginning of that
structure and how Moses is going to in
some ways establish the hierarchy he
needed for God having remembered Israel
to Now find its place because now God
has remembered Israel but there's like
distance between God and Israel you
could say so it's a it's there's this
weird suggestion in some ways God had
had forgotten or that the reality of
Israel looks like God has forgotten
Israel now God remembers Israel and he
has to God has to establish a hierarchy
of being between God and Israel in order
to let's say to be fully connected and
that's what we're going to see in in the
whole rest of the book of Exodus so if
you love if you enjoy this if you like
this discussion make sure to check out
uh The Exodus seminar on daily wire with
Jordan Peterson and some wonderful
people that is Prager uh you know and
many other very interesting interesting
thinkers that we were that we were
discussing with over a week
you know kind of looking at all these
questions together so thanks everybody
for your attention and I'll talk to you
very soon